why am i nervous we're calling right now
like I'm a little nervous he's probably
gonna be very confused I just wanted to
call and tell you something I just
wanted to call and tell you I love you
hi dad how are ya I'm good I just wanted
to call and say that I love you and I
miss you I just wanted to call and tell
you that I love you take that why do you
think dads have a hard time saying I
love you in the jaw I'll take that
that's great couple days are only for
that but that's fine I just wanted to
let you know that I love you I just
wanted to call and say that I love you
how's your day going oh I just wanted to
call and say that I love you
[Laughter]
that's awesome but I'm just calling to
say I love you bye
because I don't have fuel I just wanted
to call and tell you that I love you
thanks boss yeah that's it that's life
that's all I want to say just want to
call and tell you that thanks Bobby
hey I just wanted to say that I love you
thank you just saying I love you happy
almost Father's Day oh I got two dads I
got a stepdad that raised me and also
got a biological dad how about I call my
stepdad because he's the one that raised
me all about me what you're doing
oh I got to tell you something I just
call you to tell you that I love you no
I also want to say that I appreciate
everything you done for me you raised me
well you always been there for me and
you know you always have my back I love
you I'm very proud of you very proud of
everything you do too and I'm proud of
what you have become
as a man I know no matter what our ups
and downs but you just living proof of
that that whatever we did wrong
it came off from better because look how
you are using it yeah be there you did a
swell job in raising me you know you
don't man thank you for coming
appreciate very much
[Laughter]
right now you're overwhelmed with
emotions feels good like like you don't
hardly take time now I never took time
to really sit down but I thought thank
you for everything you done for me and
what you'd given me the man that I am
today is because of this man
you taught me man he took me on he
became a stepfather at 17 years old you
know he didn't have to do none of that
so he raised me to be a man to be tough
try to do his best to teach me
everything and love yeah it wasn't for
him I'd be in the spring sunlight
[Music]